Oppenheimer is one of the most
anticipated summer blockbusters of 2023,
and the movie's effects team made a
fantastic effort to ensure historical
authenticity in their recreation of one
of the world's most harrowing moments.
On July 16, 1945, J. Robert Oppenheimer tested
out the world's first atomic bomb in New Mexico
in the middle of an isolated desert. As
recounted in the book American Prometheus:
The Triumph and Tragedy of J. Robert
Oppenheimer, the people who witnessed
the test thought that the world ended
at the very moment the bomb exploded.
This was a terrifying and rather cinematic moment,
so it's no surprise that writer-director
Christopher Nolan had to adapt the Trinity
test for his epic biopic thriller Oppenheimer.
In a roundtable discussion with Entertainment
Weekly alongside some of the
film's stars, Nolan revealed,
"We always knew that the Trinity test
would have to be a showstopper. It's
the fulcrum that the whole story turns on."
Nolan was absolutely sure about one thing:
after featuring CGI explosions in his 2012
film The Dark Knight Rises, a digital version of
the Trinity test just wouldn't cut it. So he asked
Andrew Jackson, his visual effects supervisor
from Tenet, for help. As Nolan explained,
"I wanted to take CG off the table
and see if he could come up with
real-world methodologies for producing
the effect of the first atomic blast."
Nolan essentially wanted to peek inside
Oppenheimer's mind and come up with a
visualization of the quantum world. Luckily for
him, his effects supervisor felt comfortable in
both the digital computer realm, as well
as the analog world. As Nolan put it,
"[Jackson is] wonderful with that. And
so he spent months and months and months
doing all these experiments and
figuring out all these methods,
some very, very small and microscopic,
some of them absolutely colossal."
Jackson teamed up with special effects supervisor
Scott Fisher and production designer Ruth De Jong
to oversee the recreation of the atomic bomb.
This thrilled Nolan, even though he told his
crew that they didn't actually need to go
quite that far. As the director explained,
"When we were trying to make our
budget work, it was like, well,
what do you need to see of the gadget itself?"
"And I was like, 'Well, we only
see it in these shots and those
shots,' and they ignored that completely from me."
Nolan wasn't expecting his team
to design a version of the bomb in
such exacting detail. But that was
exactly what they ended up doing,
which allowed the production to move forward
in an exciting direction. As Nolan recounted,
"We were then free to shoot the entire process,
the shrink wrapping on it as it comes
up in the truck that gets cut off,
the way that the different modules are
inserted in and wired up. We were able
to build the tension up to the detonation by
showing that process that they went through."
Nolan was also able to use replicas of the
bunkers that Oppenheimer and his colleagues
were stationed in before the Trinity test
and during its aftermath. Specifically,
production designer Ruth De Jong built the
bunkers in such a way that they could shoot
in the desert in the middle of the night.
This allowed the actors to essentially
vicariously experience what the actual historical
figures went through in the leadup to the test.
Nolan is famously a stickler for authenticity,
such as when he shot the rotating hallway scene
in 2010's Inception with mostly practical effects.
And it seems like everything came together
perfectly once again for Oppenheimer,
from the weather to the incredible efforts
of the production team. In particular,
shooting in the New Mexico desert paid
off handsomely. As Nolan explained,
"All of it just informs the whole drama of
the piece, and the build-up to Trinity is the
key — it's really all about the tension leading
up to it, and the process that they went through."
"The revelation of the first
atomic explosion to the world
was one of the most important
moments in the 20th century."